there have been some major changes to
Captain America for Brave New World now
we knew that they were going to do
re-shoot for the movie and that the
script was basically being Rewritten but
we didn't know that it would change this
much and for those fans who are really
excited like myself for X-Men 97 we
finally have some inside information
about when to expect that first trailer
and the actual release date so far
Marvel with their upcoming projects
haven't really given us a release date
for much the best that we have for a lot
of these projects is simply the year
2024 like Agatha coven of chaos or
darkhold diaries whatever they decide to
name the finalized version of the Agatha
series Spider-Man freshman year which is
now called your friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man and X-Men 97 which we've been
told will come out in 2024 most likely
on the earlier side of 2024 and that
looks to be the case so a lot to break
down today including how Captain America
Forest changes could really affect the
rest of the MCU so if you love Marvel be
sure to subscribe so you don't miss out
on any of the latest news we're also
giving away a PS5 and Xbox series X and
more items all you got to do to enter is
subscribe and leave a comment down below
we pick one winner at the end of each
month and the winner picks one item so
originally as you might have heard with
Captain America 4 we've done several
reports about it on the channel insiders
were talking about it and stating that
it was going to be sort of a mini
Avengers film and was going to set up a
lot of things that were going to happen
in the future of the MCU like World War
Hulk and the new Avengers film and it
was the movie That was supposed to bring
the New Avengers together in fact one
report stated that this is where we'll
start to see the new Avengers team and
from what we heard at first it made
sense since Captain America was going to
go up against thadius Thunderbolt Ross
who is going to be the president of the
United States in the movie it would make
sense that he would need other Avengers
especially since they're going to
discover that he is Red Hulk and that he
is kind of creating some other Hulks as
well via a new super soldier program or
maybe an old one who knows he probably
hasn't stopped since the Hulk film so
needless to say if Captain America Sam
Wilson's Captain America was going up
against Red Hulk plus a few other and I
use air quotes here hulks he would
probably need some help so it made sense
that some other characters who were
going to be a part of the new Avengers
team would be in this film but according
to a recent report today that has
changed an account on Twitter stated
this rumor Report with re- shoots going
on it's r red these Heroes will show up
in Captain America Brave New World
She-Hulk moonight Hulk Captain Marvel
shangqi now with the exception of
moonight these are pretty much the
characters that we know are going to be
a part of the new Avengers team moonight
is still one of those up in the air
characters right now whether or not he's
going to get a second season and when
exactly he's going to show up again in
the MCU we know he will but is it going
to be in the new Avengers movie AKA
Avengers 5 or is it going to be in
Avengers Secret Wars or maybe even a
midnight Suns movie if they decide to do
that before Secret Wars so we knew most
of these characters were going to be in
the New Avengers but according to Daniel
Richmond who replied they're not in it
and won't be in it so based off of that
it does seem like the script really has
changed for Captain America Brave New
World which I think is a good thing from
what we've heard about this movie it
didn't exactly go too well in the
beginning they started filming kind of
looked at what they had and decided hey
we're going to basically redo everything
maybe not 100 per everything but a good
majority of the film from what we heard
before the final scene was going to be
red Hulk versus Sam Wilson's Captain
America and apparently they looked at
that and they decided that it wasn't
that good now I'm sure the final scene
will still be Red Hulk versus Captain
America however it's probably going to
be a completely different scene and this
is good news I've talked about this a
few times on the channel the fact that
they are willing to delay and postpone
projects to get them right to make them
better is a good thing it does sound
like Kevin fagy the president of Marvel
Studios and Disney's Bob Iger are really
trying to make sure that they don't
release anything new that isn't really
good quality now these changes might
also come from changes made to Avengers
5 and quite honestly some other films as
well that we might not know are going
through some changes it does sound like
Kevin fogy and Bob Iger are kind of
going through all the projects that they
have right now and are determining
whether or not to keep them not keep
them reshoot start over completely
basically analyzing everything they have
coming out making sure it's up to
Quality but since everything happened
with Jonathan majors and they are
recasting Jonathan Majors but seemingly
want to keep Kang on the sideline for
the moment so everything kind of dies
down there are definitely some major
changes coming to Avengers 5 before it
was reported that there were going to be
several films that really brought all
the new Avengers into the spotlight and
then they would all come together
officially in the New Avengers film but
now it sounds like the coming together
The Avengers assembling part of the new
Avengers team is is going to happen in
the movie because right now as it stands
there aren't many places that Captain
Marvel shangqi Ant-Man and the WASP
there are not many places that they
could really show up together they're
not going to show up in Agatha coven of
chaos or iron heart or Daredevil born
again or blade or in the Thunderbolts
they're just not going to show up as a
team as a unit in these films so it
makes sense that they would all assemble
in the actual Avengers movie whereas
before we heard that they were going to
start to assemble in Captain America 4
in World War h Hulk or whatever the Hulk
Solo movie is going to be and in
Spider-Man 4 where right now Ant-Man and
Daredevil are rumored to make an
appearance all of these plans could have
changed because of Captain America 4
changing and of course the new Avengers
film changing as well due to the outcome
of the Jonathan major trial but
thankfully there is a project that is
seemingly disconnected from everything
X-Men 97 which it should be the only
thing it's really connected to is the
old X-Men animated series and so far
insiders have stated that they've heard
nothing but good things from their
sources about about this show and
according to the very reliable Insider
account cryptic HD quality a trailer for
X-Men 97 is prepared which of course
means we should be getting it soon
probably not before the Deadpool 3
trailer but maybe at the same time
meaning maybe the Super Bowl now I'm
going to say probably not they're
probably going to want to keep the focus
on Deadpool but it is a possibility if
not I'm sure it's going to come soon
after because in this report from
cryptic HD quality they stay a release
date is currently unknown to me I also
received word that the series may drop
on the 20th of March so a possible
release date there if it is indeed
coming in March we should be receiving
the trailer very soon possibly next week
even because March 20th is a little over
a month away it's a month and 15 days
away which means we should have already
had the trailer for it at least a teaser
but we haven't yet so if this release
date is indeed when they are releasing
it expect a trailer for X-Men 97
extremely soon probably right after
Deadpool and also with this news means
that cinemacon 2024 this year which
we've heard Disney is going to attend in
Marvel Studios as well cinemacon comes
out in April of this year so if X-Men 97
comes out before Cinema con that means a
slot is open for Marvel Studios to show
us something new for another project we
were speculating that at cinemacon
Marvel would show us another trailer for
Deadpool and then whatever else is up
and coming X-Men 97 being the next one
but if it releases before that means we
are most likely probably going to
receive the official trailer for Agatha
coven of chaos if it hasn't released yet
by S mcon or a clip from Agatha coven of
chaos or darkle diaries as they're
calling it now so really a lot of big
things are coming from Marvel Studios
within the next few months it's a really
exciting time especially knowing that
Marvel Studios right now really is doing
what they can to make sure they release
really great highquality content that
the fans are going to love so let me
know what your most excited about in the
comments down below for me it's got to
be the Deadpool 3 trailer coming
hopefully this weekend fingers crossed
but let me know what your thoughts are
right now don't forget to like this
video And subscribe so you can stay up
to date on all the recent MCU news you
can find us on Instagram and Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof